so obviously as you can tell here the
Pete Home Show we love to make silly
silly jokes all the time
silly silly jokes that's what I put on
my tax form I tell silly silly jokes but
some jokes out there in the real world
that I think all of us are making need
to be retired which is why we made this
segment called joke retirement not is
over bringing it back here's what I'm
sure you've all heard I check this out
hmm that risotto was delicious I clean
my plate Oh guess you didn't like it
yeah we've all been there guess you
didn't like it you know what she doesn't
like you she hates you for making that
joke when she obviously loved her food
and therefore devoured all of it guess
he didn't like it consider yourself
retired it's done but I know are you
thinking some of you hey I'm a waiter
Pete what am I supposed to say to live
my life and have some fun when a
customer cleans their plate I got you
covered why don't you just say the truth
we all know what you're really saying
that risotto was delicious I clean my
plate
uh guess you're a fat I really am
yeah
that is so much better Jackson Foy's and
these guys good night